22 stop i have something to tell you you
might know everything about your
favorite pixar characters
every line every lyric and every dance
move but what about the voices behind
them
have you ever wondered if the pixar
characters you love the most
are actually being voiced by real life
actors and not just that
but huge celebrities well we're right
there with you
and you might be totally surprised to
find out who the voices responsible for
our animated faves really
are hey champ where'd all your friends
go pixar's newest soon-to-be animated
classic
is soul one of the most heartwarming
toe-tapping
totally wonderful movies to come out in
a long time
the film stars none other than jamie
foxx as joe
a high school band teacher with a love
for jazz is where it all started
this is the moment where i fell in love
with jazz
alongside fox is the hilariously
talented tina fey who plays 22
and angela bassett a legendary actress
who you might know most recently for
playing the voodoo queen
and other roles in american horror story
but that ain't you
sis inside out is definitely one of the
best pixar movies to come out in a long
time
even though it made us ugly cry for
hours after the credits finish
rolling the film all about the feelings
that exist inside of all of us at all
times was a huge hit
definitely due to the amazing cast of
voices they had behind every role
amy poehler led the pack as joy and was
the perfectly bubbly person to bring the
character to life
alongside polar was mindy kaling as
disgust and phyllis smith from the
office as sadness
yeah find the fun i don't know how to do
that
when we found out that chris pratt and
tom holland would be teaming up outside
of the marvel universe
we couldn't have been more excited pratt
and holland star as
two 11 year old brothers who go on an
epic adventure to resurrect their father
but only for one day it's a heartwarming
story
and the two movie stars are awesome
playing off one another
command it i am commanding it i'm just
clearly not good at this it also
features academy award winner octavia
spencer as the manticore we loved the
original incredibles so much
we actually couldn't believe that it
could get any better but
with the incredibles 2 somehow it did of
course they had to bring back the
original family cast to reprise their
roles
which includes the amazing holly hunter
and craig t nelson as
bob and helen parr they also had no
choice but to bring back
samuel l jackson as frozone
[Music]
and for the sequel they added some
awesome new characters
like void voiced by none other than
sophia bush
i just want to thank you for like for
being you
when brave came along we fell in love
with its heroine
merida i am merida merida was no
disney princess this scottish warrior
didn't need a prince to do anything for
her and she had the best hair of all of
them
merida was voiced by scottish actress
kelly mcdonald who you might recognize
as none other than helena ravenclaw
herself from harry potter and the
deathly hallows part 2.
i cannot help you when we first met dory
the blue fish with a short-term memory
problem in finding nemo we were totally
won over
a problem buddy huh huh do you do you do
you
for finding dory pixar had no choice but
to bring back the hilarious ellen
degeneres to reprise her iconic role
but they also added a ton of new voices
including not one
but two modern family alumni both ed
o'neill and ty burrell join the cast
along with the legendary diane keaton
and we
know you'll never forget us when it came
to choosing the voices to bring the
characters to life
the crew spared no expense in bringing
on some of the funniest people around
patton oswalt leads the cast as remy the
rat alongside the hilarious janine
garofalo as colette
and none other than lego batman himself
will arnett as horst
i killed a man with this dumb up
isn't the same kind of star-studded
movie as we've talked about before
like the incredibles or inside out but
when it comes to the voice of the
precocious little boy scout with many
badges russell
that doesn't matter russell quickly
works his way into our and
eventually carl's heart and the
directors really didn't want to cast a
kid who sounded too much like a trained
actor for this part
so they went with the adorable jordan
the guy and the rest is history
i'll give the food for him i'll walk him
i'll change
his newspapers when he was only 13 years
old
child actor anthony gonzalez won the
role of miguel in this incredibly
heartwarming and musical movie
and he totally holds his own even when
working against huge latino stars like
benjamin bratt and gail garcia-bernal
musician team musician
i need a favor to give us a little look
into the lives of our favorite scare
artists before they became famous
pixar brought back the iconic voices of
john goodman and billy crystal to
reprise their roles as sully and mike
james b sullivan mike wazowski
but they also added a handful of the
funniest people out there
including aubry plaza john krasinski
nathan fillion and sean hayes
i'm a dance major and i'm not toy story
was pixar's first ever movie
and their first huge hit it was so
successful that it spawned four sequels
and each one was somehow more amazing
than the last and there wasn't an actor
out there who
didn't want to be part of the beloved
series when it came to number four
the cast includes none other than keanu
reeves as duke kaboom
ali maki as giggles mcdimples keegan
michael key and jordan peel as ducky and
bunny
i am buzz lightyear space ranger
the third movie in the cars franchise
was able to bring in a whole group of
brand new celebs to lend voices to some
of their new characters
along with bringing back the infamous
voice of owen wilson to reprise his role
as the red racing car lightning mcqueen
they added army hammer's notorious
baritone to the mix as jackson's storm
you have no idea what a pleasure it is
for me to finally beat you
and the gorgeous carrie washington as
natalie certain to round out the already
star-studded cast
the racing world is changing the good
dinosaur might not have been a super
smash hit like toy story or monsters inc
but this heartwarming story about an
unlikely friendship between an
apothesaurus named arlo and a young
human named spot actually
features a couple of oscar winners anna
paquin stars alongside frances mcdormand
and if you listen closely you might hear
the famously rumbling voice of sam
elliott you can't get rid of fear it's
like mother nature
while most of the dialogue in wall-e
takes place in one-word exchanges
between wally and eva
[Music]
there are actually actors behind our two
favorite robots
and of course they had to add in a few
famous faces
uh voices sigourney weaver came on to
provide the soothing voice of the ship's
computer
your day is very important to us and the
adorable comedy legend fred willard
signed on to play shelby forthright see
you back home real soon
along with canadian comedy star dave
foley as skip
the film featured the talents of julia
louise dreyfus and a very
adorable and very young hayden
panettieri as princess dot
but not just that making her big screen
debut
long before she would become a bonafide
disney star ashley tisdale secured a
part in a bug's life
as the lead blueberry scout
did you know that toy story was the
first movie ever to feature
entirely computer-generated animation it
really was the first of its kind
and pixar knew they had struck gold
especially with a cast that includes
legends like tom hanks as woody and tim
allen as buzz lightshear leading the
pack
and you my friend are responsible for
delaying my rendezvous with star command
while we already mentioned that owen
wilson gave voice to the beloved race
car lightning mcqueen
the cars movie just wouldn't be the same
without larry the
i cable guy charge of hunting him down
if he tried to escape the beloved
comedian voiced the role of mater the
hilarious and lovable tow truck with the
two giant front teeth
i don't know i got nothing i guess i
ain't dark when it comes to that
even though some voice actors might not
become household names
that doesn't mean that their voices
don't hold a special place in our hearts
these two actresses definitely fit that
criteria the first is mary gibbs
who was only three years old when she
recorded this beloved character
and secondly we have the unmistakable
voice of jennifer tilly who plays mike's
girlfriend celia
i'm thinking about getting it cut and
who can be seen as bonnie swanson on
family guy
oh my goodness how did that get in there
i do
not say blah blah blah ever wonder who's
behind the hilarious voices of your
favorite vampire family
hotel transylvania has become a huge
franchise since the first movie was
released back in 2012.
it's gone on to produce two more sequels
and recently announced part four is on
the way
while we are totally invested in the
captivating adventures of characters
like dracula
mavis and all of their monster friends
we guarantee that you'll be shocked when
you hear just what star-studded celebs
are behind the voices of your favorite
animations
let's go let's do this oh my gosh this
is gonna be so much fun
how could we start with anyone other
than the scary count dracula himself
this voice actor might have been a
little difficult for viewers to figure
out just because of his stellar fake
accent you've most likely watched this
hollywood celeb as the star in plenty of
comedies
and usually he's featured alongside 90s
icons like jennifer aniston and drew
barrymore uh
any guesses that's right it's adam
sandler
sandler has starred in all three films
so far and is slated to star in the
upcoming fourth movie we knew dracula's
actor couldn't have been that
intimidating if you love his work as
dracula
you can spot him in movies like
grown-ups just go with it
and 50 first dates it's just a normal
hotel
nothing going on here the lovable mavis
is next
she might just be less scary than her
father even if she can turn into a bat
if you grew up watching 2000's disney
you definitely know who the actress is
behind this vampire s
let's just say that this is not her
first rodeo when it comes to starring in
a supernatural production from disney
star to world renowned pop star this
celeb has become a household name
the one and only selena gomez like
sandler
she worked in all three films and will
reportedly be returning for a fourth fun
fact
adam sandler actually recruited his
daughter sadie sandler to voice the
young
version of mavis don't take my candy
baby claws you don't need to be
frightened
just like mavis and eventually dracula
we all fell in love with the clumsy and
very human jonathan
while his actor doesn't have flaming red
hair jonathan's goofiness can
definitely be seen in some of his other
projects like brooklyn nine-nine and
saturday night live
hotel transylvania is just more of a
g-rated take on his humor it's
california's very own
andy samberg he's a start alongside
gomez and sandler for the past three
movies but has
yet to be announced for the fourth
fingers crossed your dad is going to
love this murray the mummy is so epic
that he's had two famous celebs bring
his voice to life
no pun intended in the first film murray
was played by a 2000s music star turned
writer and producer but after wrapping
part 1
this singer put his famous lyric to
action and said forget you
who could have ever guessed that he was
originally played by
ceelo green murray in parts 2 and 3 had
even more flavor
you might recognize this voice from
another more adult cartoon
called rick and morty or even in some
smaller roles in disney cartoons like
toy story 4 and the lion king
keegan michael key who do you think
played murray better
super cursed only the best straight from
the crib
the actor behind frankenstein might be
considered almost as iconic in the
comedy world as sandler himself whether
you've seen him in movies like paul
blart mall cop or grown-ups or in his
long-running series the king of queens
he's undoubtedly made you giggle who
knew we would see the day
kevin james would voice a cartoon in a
children's movie
he's been providing hotel transylvania
fans with laughter since 2012
just like the rest of the og characters
there's been no news on whether he'll be
returning as one of dracula's sidekicks
for the fourth film
so you still want to hang with us yeah
i'll hang whenever you want
we couldn't have frankenstein without
the bride of frankenstein or as hotel
transylvania fans know her
eunice this character is a little less
known compared to her counterparts but
just as hilarious from working in
productions like the nanny and happily
divorced fran
drescher has been bringing her humor to
the big screen since the very beginning
of the franchise
i think that we can all agree that she's
the perfect partner for frankenstein
everybody just please watch the hair
griffin is played by yet another
grown-ups alumni at this point hotel
transylvania should just be renamed a
grown-up's reunion this actor has worked
closely with adam sandler multiple times
even starring in multiple films from
sandler's production company happy
madison films
he recently released a new netflix movie
it's called the wrong
missy and has lent his talents to
classic episodes of saturday night live
it's david spade everyone
we couldn't imagine anyone else playing
the iconic invisible man for the past
three films
but you're the one in denial
wanda might just be a werewolf in all
three hotel transylvania films but in
real life she's well known for so many
hit tv shows and blockbuster movies
from starring in the series will and
grace to having a role in movies like
the santa claus 2
shallow howl and scary movie you might
say that she's
a superstar that's right it's iconic 90s
and 2000 star molly shannon hopefully
she returns for the fourth film
i think we do whatever we want
this next character was only featured in
the third film but she definitely left
her mark as the main antagonist
erica van helsing while this actress
might have a hard time topping her evil
cruise director role in the hotel
transylvania films
she has a resume stacked with roles in
other huge movies
you might have spotted her in
blockbuster hits like bad moms
tomorrowland and step brothers
katherine hahn is her name hotel
transylvania's casting director needs a
major award
asap oh that was incredible
the celeb behind wayne's character has
plenty of experience in voice acting
in fact he's a pretty important
character in another little animated
franchise called monsters inc you may
have heard of it not only does steve
buscemi have the honor of playing
wanda's husband but he's also the voice
actor behind randall from the monster
zinc films
you can also catch him alongside adam
sandler in the 90s film big daddy it
really does seem like adam sandler just
rounded up all of his past co-stars and
gave them roles hey we're not
complaining hey also
is it us or are wayne and randall
actually super similar characters
oh well that's better than nothing
if we needed more proof that adam
sandler called the shots when it came to
casting we only have to look at the
voice behind wanda
and wayne's daughter winnie you guessed
it it's his daughter sadie again
she got the opportunity to voice not one
but two characters in all three films
can adam sandler adopt us she's also had
roles in films like just go with it
the wrong missy and grown-ups
[Music]
you'll never guess the voice behind the
character of kraken who was featured in
the third film he may not be a hollywood
actor but he's
definitely left his mark in the world of
music we'll give you a hint he sings in
a band alongside his two brothers
and may or may not have got to start as
a disney star
joe jonas did you guess the right jonas
huh it's only fitting that he'd lend his
vocal talents for the film
we couldn't think of anyone better to
give us that comedic relief it's party
time
voice actors come in all ages for this
movie including
this hollywood veteran who lent his
experience to the role of vlad
they definitely needed someone
experience to play a villain in the
second film and then a hero in the next
not to mention he would have to rival
adam sandler for playing the best
vampire
you may remember him for the retro movie
spaceballs or recognize his voice from
the original muppets
drum roll please it's mel brooks
we'd love to hear more call my people
models were not excluded from this cast
roster either
crystal who was featured in the third
film was voiced by a previous sports
illustrated model she also happens to be
a huge internet personality known for
her candid but hilarious posts
need some more hints she's married to
grammy award-winning artist john legend
uh
yeah you know it chrissy teigen at your
service although her character was
invisible
just her voice alone brought the spunk
the movie needed not to mention it
proved that griffin
really did have a girlfriend this is
like the nicest hotel i've ever been to
we couldn't make this video without
giving you all the deets on mavis and
jonathan's son
the very adorable dennis he may not be
your traditional vampire but his actor
played him perfectly
especially considering that he was only
six when the second film was made
asher blinkoff has also used his young
talent in films like the jungle book
live action
and the children's cartoon sing just
look how cute he is
this is bob say hi bob
good old stan the third film wouldn't
have been the same without him
while he wasn't featured in the first
two films his voice actor actually was
this celeb not only worked out stan but
brought the character fly from the first
two films to life as well
you've definitely seen this actor around
he's worked in productions like
grown-ish and 21 jump street
and he got his start in voice acting in
shows like family guy and rick and morty
tada it's chris parnell welcome to the
bermuda triangle
bella may be only in the second film but
vlad just
wouldn't have seemed as evil without him
he was truly the mastermind behind all
of vlad's plans
it's no wonder that they had such an
experienced actor to fill in the role
with a resume packed with credits like
the daily show
modern family and brooklyn nine-nine rob
riggle was the obvious choice
we wouldn't blame you if you totally
missed him in the third film
why doesn't anybody get that past
saturday night live actors aren't
lacking when it comes to this cast
dana from hotel transylvania 2 was
played by an snl veteran that your
parents almost
definitely know he also lent his voice
talents to hilarious animated films like
life of pets and the 1992 comedy wayne's
world alongside mike myers
also known as shrek dana carvey has
definitely learned from the past while
his role is small in hotel transylvania
it's definitely hilarious who else could
train a bunch of baby vampires
hunky pokey see at the campfire
the phantom of the opera is here and
he's voiced by
of course another hollywood celeb it
looks like hotel transylvania even set a
standard of casting for their minor
characters
you undoubtedly have laughed at this
actor's hilarious jokes and his roles on
saturday night live
the simpsons netflix is insatiable and
grown-ups too
it's john lovitz who knew a stand-up
comedian would be the one to play the
mysterious phantom of the opera
not us
[Music]
the phantom may have only been around in
the second movie but
john lovitz has been around for longer
in the first film he also voiced the
eerie character quasimodo
they don't even sound similar this is
just too much talent
for us to handle i will be human but
remember how we told you that adam
sandler's daughter played a pretty big
role in the franchise
well she wasn't the only one in the
family who scored a role in the movies
it's a family affair can you guess who
voiced the character martha in the first
films
she was also given roles in movies like
grown-ups the wrong missy
paul blart mall cop and big daddy it's
his wife jackie sandler
of course it's fitting that she would
also play his on-screen wife even if
it was an animated film honey go hide
i'll take care of this that's weird
my pants drank miles we'll give you that
becoming spider-man is a weird process
but what's even more weird
or maybe shocking is a better word is
how many huge celebs are the voices
behind the heroes and villains in the
film
did you hear any familiar voices when
you watched the movie
okay then uh i'll see you around shamiq
moore had his work cut out for him when
it came to bringing miles morales to
life
not only was he taking on a character
that has a huge comic book following
but he was also bringing a version of
spider-man to the screen that we'd never
seen before
he really channeled that teen angst
despite being 10 years older than miles
in real life
and there's no other spider-man like
miles morales want to be even more
impressed
this was one of shamik's first big time
movies and he
absolutely nailed it i love
you if you want more of shamiq you can
watch him in the netflix film
let it snow and he's also filming for
into the spider verse too
you know peter parker but do you know
peter b parker
into the spider verse gets a little
confusing with its different multiverses
which also means different peter
parker's
this could literally not get any weirder
jake johnson well
his voice gave us a version of peter
parker that isn't the young
agile and hope-filled spider-man we're
used to but that doesn't mean he didn't
do an amazing job
he brought peter b parker's wit and
determination to life
and it's really no surprise considering
he was one of the stars of the hit
comedy series
new girl who else could have been a
better choice to voice the sweet gwen
stacy than the pitch perfect star
herself
we knew as soon as we heard her belt out
flashlight in pitch perfect 2
that she'd be going places haley might
look quite a bit different from her
spider-verse character
her white blonde hair is a dead giveaway
but her voice was
on point i'm from another dimension
i mean another another dimension from
the regular day-to-day teenager to the
spider woman we definitely deserve to
see more of
haley brought it all to gwen whether
he's playing nicholas devereaux in the
princess diaries 2 or
james kirk in star trek there's no
denying he
lights up the screen after watching into
the spider verse
the same thing can honestly be said for
his voice he voices peter parker
yes there's another one perfectly the
physical similarities between the two
characters aren't too similar but he got
peter parker's attitude
down packed i know you're trying to do
and it won't work marshalla ali didn't
just voice uncle aaron
aaron had more than one persona
including the threatening villain
prowler
that marshalla had to embody through his
voice
i'll find him
you know me sir i don't ever quit the
versatility he had throughout the film
was phenomenal
if you think marshalla looks just a
little too familiar
you probably recognize him from his time
in the hunger games films
as boggs he was also in the epic movie
hidden figures
and the series house of cards lily
tomlin is a voice acting veteran
and you're not alone if aunt may's voice
brought up some 90s nostalgic childhood
memories you just couldn't place
follow me lily tomlin as aunt may sounds
so familiar because she's
actually the voice behind miss frizzle
from the magic school bus
are you mind blown yet not to mention
she's been featured in shows like grace
and frankie
desperate housewives and the pink
panther film let's all admit it miles
becoming the second spider-man
and the entire into the spider-verse
film would not have happened without the
character rio morales
that's why he's tough on you you know
that right a lot of the time
heroes are all about their family and
rio was the best family miles had
now the voice behind rio actually
belongs to actress
luna lauren
if you've wondered where you've seen her
before she starred in the first purge
and has been on shows like how to get
away with murder and
ugly betty her name alone is iconic
but this actress has proved herself 10
times over to be someone other than just
lenny kravitz's daughter and her voice
acting for mary
jane is just the cherry on top she may
look
nothing like her animated character but
her voice brought life into mary jane
oh don't be sorry it's just bread if you
want to check out some of her other work
she starred in fantastic beasts
divergent
x-men and is even dabbling in the world
of dc with her upcoming role
in the batman stan lee the man
the legend the creator of spider-man
himself
how couldn't he have a role in into the
spider-verse although short
the creators made sure to honor stan
with a short cameo
he voices a shop owner named stan who
sells miles morales his spider-man suit
i'm going to miss him talk about a scene
being symbolic we don't know about you
but we never really thought we'd be
seeing a pig version of spider-man
ever my name is peter porker
but spider-ham made his appearance in
into the spider-verse and he's voiced by
the perfect celeb
john mullaney his humor and unique voice
acting made spider-ham
a true star john's comedy experience and
time on saturday night live
definitely prepped him perfectly for the
role what does orange is the new black
and spider-man into the spider-verse
have in common kamiko glenn
she played brook soso on the jail series
and also voiced the unstoppable penny
parker
hello
[Music]
she's yet another version of spider-man
and brought her own power to the screen
after into the spider-verse kimiko kept
up her voice acting in shows like
ducktales and summer camp island
we're used to seeing nicholas cage
playing his usual fatherly and
adventurous character but he mixed
it up for his voice in spider-man into
the spider-verse
he voiced spider-man noir is that all
you got you're gonna fight you're just
pumping gums you hard-boiled turtle
slapper
yes another version of spider-man that
comes from the time of the great
depression
wondering where you've seen nicholas
cage before you probably know him as
ghost
writer blink and you'll miss this quick
cameo
but yup post malone made a voice roll
appearance in the film and it wasn't
just his music
of course his music specifically his
song sunflower
was featured heavily and into the
spiderverse but he also voiced a
brooklyn bystander
as added commentary during a dramatic
spider-man mission scene
yeah i think it's a banksy jefferson
davis also known as miles morales dad
was voiced by actor brian tyree
why aren't you at school it's okay
if you've watched child's play boardwalk
empire and this is
us you've probably spotted brian a few
times before hearing him as jefferson
catherine han might be the voice actress
that looks the most like her animated
character
my enemies call me doc ock besides the
whole
evil scientist vibe of course if you're
looking for more of catherine's humor
you can watch her in bad moms
and parks and recreation ray donovan
x-men
origins spider-man into the spider-verse
they all have one thing in common
they feature actor leave schreiber in
into the spider-verse
leave voices wilson fisk one of the most
notorious super villains in the world of
spider-man
you're not stopping this not today
being an x-men this wasn't leaf's first
rodeo in the world of superheroes
no wonder he killed this role despite
natalie morales and her last name she's
not related to the one and only miles
morales
instead she voices miss caleros she
doesn't have a huge role in into the
spider-verse but she does play miles as
teacher and pulls off
all the teacher vibes perfectly you're
late again
remember how we mentioned leave
schreiber got to play villain wilson
fisk
well he didn't work alone he had help
from his evil minions scorpion
who's voiced by actor joaquin cozio what
justice
marvin crondon jones iii also played an
evil villain sidekick named tombstone
marvin brought his past work experience
to really give the character his final
touches when it came to developing his
voice
you messed up big time kid very sloppy
then we have edwin h bravo he definitely
didn't have the biggest role in the film
but his scenes as a security guard for
brooklyn visions
really brought the comedic relief the
audience needed in the film
edwin has been featured in comedy shows
like shameless and silicon valley
wow seriously i just have to ask you how
are you pulling this off
are you a genius at guessing celeb
voices then why don't you give some of
these underrated characters a try
from the movie that ariana grande and
bella thorne starred in together to
kristen bell's cool cameo in zootopia
this list is full of your favorite stars
and the movies they
rocked there's even an animated flick
that reunited three huge nickelodeon
stars but can you guess who they are
let's dive in and find out oh my gosh
this is gonna be so much fun
the actress who voiced jay in the angry
birds movie too
is best known for being an amazing role
model and also for her time on dance
moms
she's had a special on nickelodeon where
we got to peek inside of her world
and she's recorded hit songs like
boomerang so what's your best guess
it's the iconic jojo siwa who didn't
only voice hatchling j in the hit movie
but also kira the eagle
she spoke to just jared jr about her
characters and said that the trickiest
part was matching her voiceover to the
already completed animation
she also told them that she hopes jay
eventually gets her own spin-off
and we'd love to see it and my floof
yeah
even your cute little flute it's like
you're gonna be okay
a disney channel star took on the role
of ella in the same movie
this actress is an amazing singer best
known for roles and descendants and liv
and maddie
she's also a phenomenal live performer
she brought her skills to hairspray live
in the role of amber von tussell
do you think you know who she is of
course it's doug
cameron disney channel royalty who's
definitely got the whole package
dove's role as ella isn't her only voice
acting credit
she also voiced a superhero she's the
voice of gwen stacy also known as
spider-gwen
in the ultimate spider-man and marvel
rising tv shows
everyone's so caught up and dishing out
punishment they never
stopped to ask me if i was actually
guilty you definitely know the actor
chosen to voice chuck
another angry birds character he starred
in the live-action beauty and the beast
and he was
on broadway in the book of mormon but
his best role
probably the voice of olaf in disney's
frozen think you know who it is
yep that's right it's josh gad he also
voiced lewis
in ice age continental drift and damon
on
bob's burgers it was also wendell the
bug and phineas and ferb
plus josh and kristen bell who voices
anna in frozen just reunited in central
park
a new animated show on apple tv fish
locust king pigeon and of course
downward duck this disney channel
superstar brought his iconic voice to
lou
in ugly dolls you're probably used to
seeing him with his brothers on stage
and in movies like camp rock
so who is he it's nick jonas our
childhood crush who can pretty much make
our hearts melt with one word
so we're not upset at all that he's been
getting into voice acting
he and his brothers had another surprise
voice acting cameo when they were pretty
young
but stick around because we'll tell you
more about that a little bit later
of course of course stay here this
singer co-starred with nick as the
character tuesday
she's super new to acting and voice
acting so you've probably only heard of
her from her many successful
songs including in the name of love and
i'm gonna show you crazy
think you know who she is it's phebe
rexa who was also the writer behind some
hit singles like eminem
and rihanna's the monster her role as
tuesday led to her starring in her very
first movie
but with a voice like that we'd love to
see bb show off her skills in another
feature animation
look listen and learn this camp rock
star won the role of smurfette
in smurfs the lost village she's a
phenomenal singer whose recent single
anyone made huge waves at the 2019
grammy awards
and she used to be really good friends
with selena gomez the two of them even
starred in a disney channel original
movie together
any idea who she could be it's demi
lovato the actress turned singer who
loved playing smurfette because they're
both fierce and resourceful
demi actually voiced another animated
character in the movie charming
she played lenore and was joined by a
fellow disney channel
star ashley tisdale who voiced
cinderella we're smurfs
we do the right thing the role of smurf
lily went to this modern family star who
has a talent for voice acting
she's also appeared in er and r.l
stein's the haunting hour
and she just so happens to have the same
name as a disney princess
who do you think it is it's ariel winter
who's super well known as alex dunphy
but she's no stranger to voice acting
she starred in tons of kids tv shows
though you probably know her best as
gretchen in phineas and ferb
and penny in mr peabody and sherman we
have to take you to smurfy grove
snowflake the white gorilla is a fun
underrated movie that stars one of the
world's most famous singers as snowflake
she's known for her role in nickelodeon
shows like victorious
and she's also known for saying thank
you next that's right
it's ariana grande we bet you didn't
know that she starred alongside icarly's
jeanette mccurdy who voiced petunia
and nathan cress who voiced elvis but
this isn't ariana's first big animated
reunion with fellow childhood stars
bella thorne may be a disney star but
she joined ariana as the young version
of her character laura
in the underdogs movie take him down
he'll play
one of saturday night live's biggest
cast members took on the role of lupe
the eccentric goat in ferdinand
she also does a really good impression
of ellen degeneres
any guesses it's kate mckinnon playing
lupe was a dream come true for kate and
she wants the character to teach kids
that staying true to yourself
is totally worth it and fun fact kate's
actually super good friends with ellen
she even got a role in ellen's latest
flick finding dory
try some deep relaxing breaths okay in
in
out the superstar who voiced queen tara
in
epic can be described as a queen in real
life
she's an iconic singer and she started
movies like dream girls
so who is she it's the one and only
beyonce
who you shouldn't even be surprised is
taking on voice acting in addition to
all of her other amazing talents
she was recently the voice of nala in
the lion king live action remake
she also helped put together the movie's
entire soundtrack
for a performer that's so incredible in
front of an audience she sure
seems just as comfortable behind the
scenes
i might have a hard time picking one do
you have a favorite
this next actress is a surprisingly good
singer which is why she got to voice ash
the rock star porcupine
insane though you probably know her
better as an epic avenger she's actually
voiced a lot of animated characters
before
like princess mindy in the spongebob
squarepants movie
think you know who she could be it's
scarlett johansson
this black widow loved being in a film
about following your dreams
it's definitely a lighter role than some
of her other ones she was the voice of
the sinister snake
kah in the live-action jungle book which
is a huge deal because all the original
movie characters were male
and they came to scarlet for the role so
that they could get more women involved
in the remake
you do yes
would you like to see sensing is pretty
big on girl power they got another epic
powerhouse vocalist to voice mina
you might remember her from season 9 of
american idol
she's also won a grammy for best gospel
album for hiding place
and she's appeared on sesame street any
guesses
it's the amazing tori kelly with the
voice of an angel it's no wonder she was
the perfect pick for mina
her favorite and also the most stressful
part of the whole process was putting
her own spin
on hallelujah this was her very first
voice acting role but since tori loved
the experience
she'll probably pop up in another
animated flick sometime
soon no i mean yes yeah i can sing
another powerhouse actress took on the
role of wife mother and secret singer
rosita
this actress has been legally blonde for
most of her life but we all knew she
could pull off singing thanks to her
well-received role in walk the line
so what's your best guess of course it's
reese witherspoon
she loved the opportunity to play a
mother who proves that she is so much
more than a housewife
but seeing isn't reese's first shot at
voice acting she also voiced susan
murphy in monsters vs aliens
look i can't even keep count of the
steps my body parts aren't responding
okay
she's a superstar singer with her own
makeup line but she was also the voice
of tip in the movie home
back in the day she was singing pone day
replay do you know her
it's rihanna the fenty queen who also
has some great voice acting chops
she co-starred in this flick with the
big bang theory's jim parsons
who kept cracking her up behind the
scenes i know
that's why it's fun the actress who
voiced tip's mother lucy is also a
successful singer
she's known for getting people on the
floor and she gave a wicked super bowl
performance in 2019.
we think you know who this superstar is
it's jennifer lopez
another woman who can really do it all
jlo is no stranger to starring in movies
but did you know that she was also the
voice of shira
in the ice age movies as for her role in
home she was chosen to record the
movie's theme song
feel the light so tell me where she is
or find me a boo who can
this world famous pop star used to do a
little acting back in the day when she
took on the role of audrey in the lorax
she's been in valentine's day and was
featured singing in hannah montana the
movie
any idea who she could be it's singer
songwriter taylor swift
she co-starred with zac efron and the
two had a blast behind the scenes while
she was recently in cats she hasn't done
a lot of acting lately
let us know in the comments where you'd
like to see taylor next
those are trees they used to grow all
around here
we know this voice actress really well
she may have voiced the tiny role of
priscilla the sloth in zootopia
but she's had a whole bunch of iconic
roles and she's also one of our favorite
disney princesses from frozen
so who is she you're right it's totally
kristin bell
she is absolutely addicted to sloth so
the small role of priscilla was a
no-brainer for her
another underrated role that you might
not know kristin took on
is harper jambowski one of lisa's rich
friends in the simpsons
oh i wish it could be like this all the
time we bet you didn't know about this
friend star who voiced sarah gardner in
storks
in the popular sitcom she was known for
her iconic hair and fashion sense
any idea who she could be it's the one
and only jennifer aniston
she admitted that the most
nerve-wracking part of taking the role
was having to hear her own voice in
surround sound
don't be crazy you cannot do the chimney
come on don't make me the mean mom
the brooklyn nine-nine star who voiced
jonathan in hotel transylvania 3 has
done pretty much
everything he's been on saturday night
live in a very lonely band
and he's starred in movies like hot rod
and pop star
never stop never stopping think you know
who he is
that's right it's andy samberg and he
has had tons of voice over roles
and you probably didn't realize that
most of these were him
he was brent mchale in cloudy with a
chance of meatballs
and junior in storks he was brett in
bob's burgers and ricky the raptor in
american dad
i gotta warn you i played second team
co-ed intramural volleyball at santa
cruz who knew that legendary sea
monsters could be such good singers
for the role of the kraken the hotel
transylvania crew needed a hip young
artist
and it doesn't hurt that he's pretty
close friends with co-star selena gomez
oh and did we mention this superstar is
best known for rocking out in a band
with his brothers
and that he's also married to a stark if
you guessed joe jonas then you got it
right
this jonas brother was the perfect
choice for a crooning kraken
but you might be surprised to find out
that this isn't joe's first or
most underrated voice acting role he and
his brothers voiced the cherubs in night
at the museum battle of the smithsonian
where they also got to show off their
signature singing voices
in fact to get things just right the
brothers want to chair a boot camp
that sounds like a once-in-a-lifetime
experience to us
he gets the groove going and everyone's
having a great time
the niece image he's not in the room
he's not by the pool
it's not in this pot of soup these
celebrities might look good on screen
but they sound good too
that's why they've lent their voices to
tons of our favorite animated icons
did you know that the riverdale girls
got to star in the simpsons
and what about all the animated roles
our favorite avenger scarlett johansson
has taken on
from the jungle book to spongebob we
know you can't wait to find out more so
let's dive in deep behind the animation
of some of our favorite cartoon
characters
bethany's changed her look it suits her
did you know that lily reinhardt camila
mendes and madeline petch
were all on the same episode of the
simpsons in an episode called the
hateful eight-year-olds
lisa tries to fit in with a group of
snobby rich girls named bella ella
voiced by lily
sloane voiced by madeline and tessa rose
voiced by camilla
this is my crew you probably know them
all from social
the riverdale girls shared their
excitement about the iconic casting
online with
lily posting a thank you and calling the
experience an incredible surreal
blessing
meanwhile camilla encouraged everyone to
go watch her and her riverdale besties
play mean and annoying eight-year-old
girls
these are actually the very first
voiceover roles for the girls
but now that they've all tried their
hand at voice acting do you think we'll
finally get an
animated episode of riverdale
zendaya is a talented actress dancer
singer she can basically do
anything and voice acting is definitely
on that list
zendaya has had a few small voice acting
roles she voiced a duck named chi
in duck duck goose a horse named
lollipop in super buddies and a human
named fern in pixie hollow games
but her best role is probably as the
yeti michie
in small foot oh wait is that that thing
where you project a series of images in
rapid succession to a large group of
people who've come to see a good story
so
what are the highlights of voicing a
fictional bigfoot well for one zendaya
got to sing the movie's theme song
wonderful life she also got to work
alongside with shannon tatum
that's gotta make any job more fun right
but cindy is really in it for the kids
she loves being a role model and isn't
about to stop voice acting anytime soon
speaking of hunky co-stars zac efron has
a lot more going on for him than just
his looks
like zendaya he can sing act and dance
and he's also lent his voice to some
pretty cool characters the latest
is fred from the new movie scoob zach
loved playing fred because he got to
feel like a powerful mystery hunter
surrounded by
friends that in his own words inspired a
generation
we need office space for a headquarters
the mystery machine needs a fresh coat
of
everything and even though it's animated
we can't help but think zack would be a
perfect fred in a new live-action
scooby-doo
but being fred isn't zack's first voice
acting gig he also starred as ted
alongside taylor swift in the lorax
where the pair were hopeful that their
environmentally conscious film could
help motivate people to change the world
zac efron's scoob co-star is amanda
seyfried who voices daphne
i can't i can't breathe and we feel the
same way about amanda as we do about
zack
she could totally pull off a live-action
daphne what amanda loved most about
voicing the super sleuth is her
compassion kindness
love for animals and that she's a great
role model for young girls and they also
had scooby snacks available to the
artist
in the recording studio daphne isn't
amanda's first try at voice acting
she voiced mary katherine in 2013's epic
alongside beyonce and josh hutcherson
tom holland and will smith might seem
like they really hit it off as voices of
walter and lance in spies in disguise
hi wow uh walter becky pleasure to meet
i could get my face burned off but the
duo never actually met face to face
until
after the movie was finished but at
least their first meeting was pretty
epic
they had to pair up to solve an escape
room as promo for the new film
but other than being pigeon-loving super
spies both actors have given their
voices to animated films before
will smith was oscar in shark tale where
he co-starred with angelina jolie who
voiced lola
as for tom holland he recently starred
with another of his bffs chris pratt in
onward the pair played brothers ian and
barley and behind the scene they
actually lost their voices from over
dedicating themselves to their roles
let us know in the comments which
bromance is your favorite
selena gomez has a lot of acting roles
under her belt but she's also slowly
becoming a voice over wizard
she voices rebellious vampire mavis in
all three hotel transylvania films with
a fourth reportedly in production okay
time for presents guys
she also got to star alongside another
disney channel alum
joe jonas in the third film he played
the very musical kraken
but before she was a vampire selena was
taking a page from zac
efron's book and bringing a dr seuss
character to life as
helga and horton hears a who she just so
happened to co-star with joey kink who
she later starred in ramona and beezus
with
and who also has some pretty impressive
voice acting gigs of her own to be proud
of
joey king recently joined the riverdale
girls in the episode of the simpsons
she played addie a nicer rich girl who
tries to get lisa to hang out with her
snobby
friends yeah it's kind of embarrassing
it might have been
only voice acting but the girls
chemistry was definitely off the charts
maybe joey king will find herself
joining the girls as a riverdale guest
star sometime soon
starring in the simpsons is a huge honor
but joey king's been voice acting for a
very long time
and joey has loved all her roles because
a kid hearing her own voice coming out
of an animated character
is pretty much a dream come true don't
worry
if you get thrown your vest will
automatically inflate so it breaks your
fault
justin timberlake and anna kendrick are
a match made in heaven
both are goofy spunky and amazingly
musical
so it's no wonder they're the co-stars
of the trolls movie with anna voicing
poppy and justin taking on the role of
branch
i could hear you from a mile away good i
was worried we weren't projecting enough
justin was also executive producer of
music for the movies
and they kept his role in the movie so
top secret that anna didn't even know
who had been cast
until he finally came in to run lines
anna joked about justin's fame on late
night with seth meyers
saying that reporters at cannes would
throw her a single question here and
there to make sure she didn't feel bad
justin's been trying his hand at voice
acting for years he voiced artie and
shrek the third
maybe this guy has feelings maybe i
should cut him some slack
anna's also a big fan of animated films
she was the voice of courtney
in paranorman so i was thinking maybe we
could catch a movie sometime
nothing scary fingers crossed that she
gets a lot more offers in the future
because there's no such thing
as too much anna kendrick
chloe grace moretz might be blonde and
full of sunshine
but her character in the addams family
is her polar opposite
i'm not locked up in here with you
bethany
you're locked up in here with me
chloe voices the iconic wednesday atoms
and has a few interesting things to say
about her experience
first she says the highlight of filming
was playing a strange girl going through
normal teenage girl issues in a very
weird family
chloe also got to work with a few other
icons like the young finn wolfhard who
voiced pugsley
even snoop dogg was a part of the addams
family he voiced cousin it
you'd probably be surprised by how many
voice acting roles scarlett johansson
has taken on
she's truly a jack of all trades and has
been voicing iconic characters for years
she was even the voice of princess mindy
in the spongebob squarepants movie
i'm gonna be queen of the sea one day
i've learned the names of all the sea
creatures
scarlett was also the snake in kaw in
the jungle book live-action movie
scarlett has also shown off her singing
voice in animated films she played the
porcupine ash in sing
and she recently took on the role of a
dog named nutmeg in the uniquely
animated isle of dogs
so next time you're watching an animated
movie and think is that scarlett
johansson
you're probably right
miley cyrus has always loved dogs so
back in her disney channel days she
signed on to voice penny in bold i
kroger guado
i should have known it was her first
ever voiceover role
since then miley's been focusing on
music a lot more than acting or
animation
but in 2019 she did star as ashley oh in
a live-action episode of black mirror
where she got to both act
and voice a robot version of her
character her voiceover roles might be
getting weirder but it's good to know
she hasn't hung up the mic for good
you know where best is elsa from frozen
but idina's very first voice acting role
was
actually as cersei on the hercules tv
series
hi boys i'm new in town i just drifted
into my big floating island of love
idina is used to being in front of an
audience she got her start in rent on
broadway and later starred in wicked the
best and worst thing about being a voice
actor is not having an audience they
might make
work more nerve-wracking but idina loves
performing for a crowd
so it's a good thing her role as elsa
gives her lots of opportunity to hop on
stage and belt one out
avatar the last airbender is a childhood
classic and you can still enjoy it as
much as an adult as you did when you
were a kid
so it's pretty cool to find out that
child star and avatar super fan mae
whitman voices our favorite waterbender
katara
no no way am i apologizing to a sour old
man like you
may is best known for her roles in
arrested development and the recent hit
good girls but she
actually got her start appearing in
independence day when she
was only eight but mei's true passion
has always been voice acting her mom is
a voice over artist
and mae loves following in her footsteps
because she finds that animated movies
give her more freedom
and always have good vibes she lied to
you
she was protecting the last water bender
me sisterhood of the traveling pants
star america ferreira
brought her fierce girl power instincts
to the voice of astrid in how to train
your dragon
get me down from here you have to give
me a chance to explain
america says that both girls and boys
can look up to astrid for her warrior
spirit
it's also super important that astrid
always goes after what she wants
while astrid has grown throughout the
franchise into an extra tough female
hero
america says that tons of things have
changed throughout the movie-making
process
and that's been one of the most exciting
parts for example
in the first movie they could only have
eight dragons on screen at once
but now that technology has grown the
third movie has over 65 000 dragons on
screen
all at the same time
dakota fanning has been lending her
voice to so many characters and you
probably
never knew half of these were her her
most popular role was the voice of
coraline in the movie of the same name
i i'd love to play but
i better get home to my other mother and
we can't help but wonder if the movie
was as creepy to her
as it was to all of us thankfully her
other animated roles are a lot less
scary
she was the voice of lilo in lilo and
stitch too and she was also the voice of
a young kim possible
in kim possible a stitch in time ford
dakota voice acting seems to have been a
fun hobby when she was younger but we
hope to see her in a brand new animated
movie sometime
soon we aren't finished yet how are we
disney may be where dreams come true but
dreamworks characters have been bringing
entertainment and humor to our screens
for decades
who do we have to thank well for
starters the a-list
casts from angelina jolie to ryan
reynolds and rihanna dreamworks movies
have to have some of the most
shocking cast members and that's why
we're revealing them all for you in
today's video
that's why i'm so dangerous a star from
la la land and deadpool walk into an
animation studio
what happens the croods of course these
two actors took a trip back in time to
bring to life the teen romance of eep
and guy have you guessed who they are
yet drum roll
please it's emma stone and ryan reynolds
so from now on we'll stay out here the
cast
also includes nicolas cage as grug and
peter dinklage as
phil this is belt cook conversationalist
navigator he also keeps my pants up
of course dreamworks hired an iconic
actor to voice boss baby
he had to be unforgettable but have you
ever picked up on who it actually is
we'll give you a hint his niece is
married to justin bieber and he's made
appearances on snl
it's alec baldwin and his co-star who
voiced janus
let's just say when she got the role her
response was probably
i'll be there for you yup it's lisa
kudrow
also known as phoebe from friends who do
you want to stay with you
daddy or mommy other voices you might
have recognized in the film are jimmy
kimmel as dad
and the amazing spider-man toby maguire
as tim
i'm the boss when we found out who was
behind the voices of the cast of home we
were
shook remember gratuity turns out she's
a pop star in disguise
her voice actor has released hit singles
like umbrella and even launched her own
makeup line
if you said rihanna you are correct but
that's not all
another pop star was also credited on
this voice cast for the role of lucy
it's the one and only jenny from the
block also known as j-lo
oh timmy my beautiful girl big bang
theory alum jim parsons also voiced oh
and steve martin made his voice
appearance as captain smek
give daddy some sugar if you were
obsessed with jack frost in rise of the
guardians
you'll realize a lot of it probably has
to do with the voice behind the
character
not chris hemsworth not chris evans but
chris pine snow day
bunnymonde also had the honor of having
a pretty epic voice actor
this a-lister has worked in movies like
the greatest showman
and wolverine yup it's hugh jackman how
how is that not offensive anna kendrick
and justin timberlake were the main
stars of trolls as poppy and branch
but the actors they worked alongside
with are equally as epic
the cast roster includes a pop star a
late night talk show host and a fifty
shades of grey star
what a combination any guesses delta was
played by kelly clarkson james corden
voices biggie and
jamie dornan voiced chaz the only
weapons we need
are this guy this guy how to train your
dragons cast list is basically made up
of hilarious comedians and a targaryen
jay barrow shell voices hiccup america
ferreira voices astrid and jonah hill is
the genius behind snotlout
eric well he had the honor of being
voiced by
jon snow himself that's right game of
thrones wasn't the only world kit
harrington was a part of that included
dragons
famous back from where i'm from who knew
the same person behind nacho libre was
the voice behind poe from kung fu panda
jack black may not seem like the person
to jump from school of rock into voice
acting but that's exactly what he did
i'm going to teach kung fu he also
brought a spiel of a-list actors along
with him
master shifu is voiced by none other
than dustin hoffman
let me show you another move and tigress
let's just say
her voice actress is the former queen of
the moors
also known as maleficent or angelina
jolie
i've seen kai i've seen what he can do
seth rogen and jackie chan were also in
the films as mantis and monkey
justice madagascar shined a light on the
nyc zoo but before alex's voice actor
could make him a star he was guarding
the same city's museum of natural
history
all right this is a little weird does
his voice sound familiar yet
alex is voiced by the one and only ben
stiller
let's check out the actors behind alex's
gang lisa kudrow wasn't the only friend
star to sign a contract with dreamworks
david schwimmer aka ross geller voices
mailman
yeah nice to uh nice to meet you chris
rock took on marty
and jada pinkett smith is behind the
glorious gloria
all righty boys fun's over remember the
character lord business in the lego
movie that's the same actor who brought
megamind to our screens
he's also everyone's favorite elf will
ferrell
but he isn't the only big name on this
cast list metro man was voiced by the
man
the myth the brad pitt and roxanne mean
girls alum tina fey took her on
i'm so tired of running rampant through
the streets
shrek has been in our lives for quite
some time however have you ever stopped
to think about the actors behind the
ogres
let's peel back those layers and uncover
the voices
the truth is shrek was basically a
comedian reunion
you have mike myers as shrek eddie
murphy as donkey
cameron diaz is princess fiona and
antonio banderas as puss in boots
how strange it was to give a cat boots
throw in the queen of genovia julie
andrews as princess fiona's mother
and you get shrek you were expecting
prince charming
who knew that the fresh prince of bel
air would one day transition into voice
acting
yes will smith was the voice behind your
childhood fave
oscar in shark tale i could paint you up
all bloody right
angelina jolie also made an appearance
in this film any guesses on what
character it was
if you said lola you are correct you got
a name
over the hedge might be an underrated
dreamworks film especially when you look
at the cast list
how could you not love the film when the
cast includes the office's michael scott
himself
yes this is happening steve carell
worked as hammy on this film
and his co-star is the star of die hard
we couldn't believe it either
bruce willis is the voice behind rj
not to mention two out of the four roses
from shit's creek were
also in this film canadian duo eugene
levy and catherine o'hara voiced
lou and penny what is that before
turbo's voice actor could land his role
in the croods he worked as the main
character of this film
take a listen to turbo's voice join your
crew
any guesses it's ryan reynolds again and
this time was joined by ken
jong as kim lee snoop dogg as smoove
we couldn't believe it either and samuel
l jackson as whiplash
i'm turbo and i've got a need for speed
flushed away might have been more
low-key than some of the movies on this
list
but you won't believe who voiced
characters roddy and
rita one has already been mentioned on
this list just
james clan flows through your veins hugh
jackman
and farida she was voiced by beautiful
titanic star
kate winslet we couldn't go through this
video without highlighting the amazing
cast of abominable
did you catch any familiar voices while
watching chloe bennett voiced yee
disney star tenzing trainer took on jyn
and the amazing
sarah paulson worked as dr zara what are
you gonna do yee
take him all the way back to mount
everest we'll never be able to watch
monsters vs aliens the same
after discovering the voices behind the
characters steve carell isn't the only
the office star to dabble in voice
acting
rayne wilson dwight schrute voiced
villain galaxar
that's just the tip of the iceberg reese
witherspoon voiced susan
seth rogan bob and even ant-man paul
rudd
took a shot at the character derek and i
want you to know
i forgive you the b movie was definitely
a wild time in dreamworks cinema but the
characters were still voiced by
pretty big actors ever heard of a little
show called seinfeld
well jerry seinfeld himself is the voice
behind main character barry
one nectar collector and vanessa she was
voiced by renee zellweger
oh to be in the tournament of roses
that's every floor stream
who knew brad pitt was so into voice
acting definitely not us
he was actually the main character in
the 2003 film
sinbad his co-stars were also pretty
epic
michelle pfeiffer voiced eris and
catherine zeta jones was marina
oh and i was overworking it if you read
these books in your childhood
you probably couldn't wait for this
dreamworks movie especially with its
cast
captain underpants himself was actor ed
helms never underestimate the power of
underwear if you thought that was
shocking wait until you find out who
played george beard
it was kevin hart oh this is going to be
epic
you strike out you resign
so many characters in zootopia sound so
familiar right well it's not surprising
as they're voiced by
major hollywood stars disney's 2016
movie has a large group of
seriously talented individuals voicing
its animal cast
from oscar winners to world famous
singers and even a disney princess
yes really join us as we take you behind
the voices to discover
who's who gosh think of the headline
we're starting off with the fox that
forms one half of zootopia's central
double act
nick wilde you might know this american
actor from his work on arrested
development or maybe you recognize his
voice from his more recent work
directing and starring in the netflix
crime drama ozark
perhaps it's his other film credits that
you're familiar with starring alongside
the likes of jennifer aniston
in horrible bosses huh you got it yet
that's right nick is voiced by jason
bateman
the movie's directors byron howard and
rich moore said
it's so distinctively jason but in a
whole new way
it's a perfect role for him and he
brings all the dry wit and attitude that
perfectly jars with the other main
character
sly fox dumb bunny where would nick be
without judy hopps
zootopia's first bunny cop brings a big
dose of much-needed optimism to nick's
world and the voice actor behind judy
actually shares that optimistic outlook
she's an american actor known for her
starring role in the hbo drama big love
and in the abc fantasy once upon a time
she's got plenty of film credits to her
name too including 2005's the musical
biopic
walk the line and 2009's rom com he's
just not that into you
this actor also has experience voicing
disney animated characters having lent
her voice to fawn and tinkerbell and the
legend of the neverbeast have you
guessed already
it's jennifer goodwin both judy and i
are
fiercely optimistic someone very close
to jennifer voiced a small part in the
movie too
stay tuned to discover more guys i've
been working for this my whole life
judy comes up against some resistance
from chief bogo
head of the zootopia police department
this tough buffalo with 2
000 pounds of attitude needs a big voice
to match and he certainly got that
the english actor behind chief bogo is
best known for his tv roles and hbo's
the wire
and the bbc's luther plus movies like
american gangster and star trek beyond
and franchises such as thor and the
avengers as well as voicing sheer khan
in the live-action jungle book and fluke
in finding dory
this actor has also taken on such
important parts as nelson mandela in the
2013 movie mandela long walk to freedom
we know that you're shouting at your
screen now
yep it's idris elba this is an
opportunity to do something it's funny
did you shake your thang to gazelle's
tune try everything in zootopia if you
love the pop star's voice
then it's probably no surprise that a
world-renowned singer stepped up to the
mic to play the part of the gazelle
and she also wrote that song especially
for the movie she's got such a
distinctive singing voice but did you
manage to figure out who she is
we've got one more clue for you this
spanish-speaking performer voices
gazelle in the spanish dubs too
you've probably worked out by now that
we're talking about shakira the awesome
colombian singer-songwriter we love
officer clawhauser's description of
gazelle
are you familiar with gazelle greatest
singer of our lifetime angel with horns
speaking of officer clawhauser who
doesn't love the zootopia police
department's most adorable cheetah his
love of donuts and gazelle
and his enthusiastic attitude must make
him a delight to voice
and the actor behind benjamin
clawhauser's voice has been in a fair
few tv shows
including the fox sitcom weird loners
and the hbo series hello ladies
if that doesn't ring any bells you might
recognize his voice from his ad work he
played a credit card customer
representative alongside david spade in
capital one's what's in your wallet
campaign his other commercials include
enterprise rent-a-car
volkswagen goldengrams and nfl.com
the man behind the cheetah is nate
torrance
oh m goodness
they really did hire a bunny zootopia
has a huge cast of characters
some of whom only have a couple of lines
case in point priscilla
the three-toed sloth who is flash's
co-worker at the dmv
in fact she only has two words but the
filmmakers managed
to get a big star to do it the actor
that voices priscilla is no stranger to
disney movies
in fact she's the voice behind one of
the studio's most famous characters of
recent years
and the casting director managed to get
this actor on board
because she revealed on the ellen show
that she loves sloths she explained how
her husband
got a sloth to come to her birthday
party and she was immediately overcome
that's right it's anna from frozen
yeah yeah kristen bell when she got
offered the part she said yes within a
couple of minutes
they describe it as the quickest deal
ever made in hollywood
yes flash
that small time crook's name is a big
giveaway as to who voices the weasel in
zootopia
duke weaselton is a reference to the
duke of weaselton from frozen
and the same actor voices both roles
he's no stranger to disney animated
movies
also voicing the parts of high high in
moana knows morin ralph breaks the
internet and alistair cray in big hero
6.
do you know the actor's name it's alan
tudyk in a fun easter egg
the bootleg dvds that duke sells
includes version of these very same
movies
wreck-it rhino pig hero 6 meow wanna
and float zen 2 you might also recognize
his voice as the droid k2so
in rogue one a star wars story it's
weaselton
duke weaselton and i ain't talking
rabbit some characters in the movie have
a really distinctive voice
and the lamb bellwether is certainly one
of those if you're familiar with the
actor's work
then having such a standout voice should
make it easier to figure out who's
behind the assistant mayor
in fact it's thanks to her idiosyncratic
voice that she got a role in the
animated sitcom bob's burgers
she's an snl alumnus that landed a
recurring role in the tv show parks and
recreation house of lies and kroll show
but her breakout role was in the 2014
movie obvious child
since zootopia she is lent her voice to
gidget in the secret life of pets
and harley quinn in the lego batman
movie we're talking
about jenny slate playing bellwether was
a dream come true for jenny
us little guys really need to stick
together right
of course we can't cover the assistant
mayor without moving straight on to the
actual mayor of zootopia
mayor lionheart the actor behind the
mayor's voice has a long list of
impressive credits to his name his tv
work includes law
and order oz the closer and counterpart
and as for movies he starred in the
spider-man trilogy
plus 2014's whiplash which won him a
whole lot of awards
then there's his voice work in gravity
falls kung fu panda 3
and various marvel animations ready for
our reveal
the man in question is jk simmons he's
spoken about how great it is to see the
range of your voice coming out in a
fantastical character
okay officer hopps let's see those teeth
the list of big stars go on with an
academy award-winning actor providing
the voice of mrs otterton
the rival otter whose husband emmett had
gone missing she might be a tiny animal
but she's got a huge star as her voice
let's drop a few clues so you can make
your guesses this american actress has
not only won an oscar but also a golden
globe and screen actors guild awards
although she made her film debut in 1996
her breakthrough role came in the 2011
movie the help following other acclaimed
film roles she's turned
to tv with the truth be told on apple tv
and
self made on netflix we probably had you
at the help but if you're still not sure
we can reveal it's octavius spencer
since zootopia octavia has also voiced
another animated character
corey the manticore in the 2020 disney
and pixar movie
onward please there's got to be somebody
to find my image
if you're a fan of pixar animated movies
then you'll probably recognize the voice
of bonnie hopps judy's mom the actor has
starred in no less than eight pixars in
fact
zootopia was her first non-pixar
animated film
although she's only got a small part in
zootopia she's got a recognizable voice
let's run through a few of her other
roles so you can get that light
bulb moment she voiced rosie in a bug's
life ms flint and monsters inc
karen graves in monsters university
sally carrera in the cars trilogy
and dolly in toy story 3 and 4. you
might actually have
seen her acting in movies like beethoven
jumanji
cheaper by the dozen jerry maguire and
the green mile
the actor we're talking about is bonnie
hunt total coincidence by the way that
she shares the same name
and we're just a little excited for you
but terrified
on the subject of prolific voice actors
the person behind jerry jumbo jr has
lent his vocal skills to many characters
over the years
so it would make sense that you'd
recognize the voice of the bad tempered
elephant who owns the ice cream parlor
the actor has been in so many animations
that it's impossible to list them all
here so we'll stick with his best known
parts
that's bender on futurama jake the dog
on adventure time
dr drakken on kim possible scotsman on
samurai jack
brother blood on teen titans schnitzel
on chowder
hammerhead and sandman on the
spectacular spider-man
aquaman on batman the brave and the bold
and king zog on the netflix series
disenchantment
it's john dimaggio we reserve the right
to refuse service
to anyone mr big is also played by a
veteran voice artist
this arctic shrew is the most feared
crime boss in tundratown he's got a band
of polar bears at his beck and call
but although the voice actor has used
his skills for many characters on screen
you might not recognize him from his
rendition of mr big that's because he
does a mafia style voice that is not in
keeping with his other roles this
canadian actor has something in common
with john dimaggio he's worked on
futurama in fact he's
voiced a variety of characters on the
mac graining animation he's also the
voice of brain
in animaniacs and the spin-off pinky and
the brain plus egon spangler in the
animated real ghostbusters tv series
the man we're talking about is maurice
la marsh i will take your
kindness and pay it forward
yax the yak is one of the best bit parts
in zootopia who can forget judy's shock
when she realizes the axe isn't wearing
any clothes and his response
we're a naturalist club the canadian
american actor who voices yaks is just
perfect for the role
after all he's a cannabis rights
activist and is known for his marijuana
theme to chichen chong comedy albums and
movies with cheech marin
you might also know him from that 70s
show it's tommy chong
told you nangi has the mind like a steel
trap
we're finishing up with a fun fact
remember how he mentioned that someone
close to jennifer goodwin also gave
their voice to a character in the movie
well now it's time to reveal the details
the character is the frantic pig who
owns the flora and fauna flower shop
that duke weaselton robs he comes
rushing out onto the street screaming at
judy to do something
the american actor behind the voice is
best known for his tv work in the abc
series once upon a time
and the nbc drama manifest he also
starred in the marvel comics film
adaptation thor
and he happens to be jennifer goodwin's
husband that's right josh and dallas
lent his voice to the frantic pig it's
so funny to watch the couple screaming
at each other in different sound booths
well are you a cop or not oh yes yes
morning fred smells like christmas
it is the most wonderful time of the
year again holiday films on repeat
if you're looking for a fresh new
addition to step up your usual
elf love actually holiday movie binge
then look no further than 2018's
animated family movie
the grinch oh mr grinch i'm so happy you
decided to come
it is a more modern and humorous take on
the classic dr seuss tale how the grinch
stole
christmas as an added bonus this movie
is full of a star-studded cast
their voices sound so familiar you're
sure you can put your finger on it but
others may surprise you i say something
like yeah yeah yeah have a nice life
it may come as a surprise that english
actor benedict cumberbatch
stars as the story's infamous mean one
mr grinch
cumberbatch has a lengthy history in
global television and film
with some of his most notable roles
being sherlock holmes in sherlock and dr
steven strange in doctor strange
he also gave an impressive performance
as smaug in the hobbit
where not only was his voice acting
top-notch but they also used motion
capture where he physically acted like a
real dragon
you have nice manners
he was also nominated for best actor at
the 2015 oscars for his role as alan
turing in the imitation game
so having benedict voice the grinch
couldn't be better
behold the presence this is
our enemy his dialogue as the grinch is
humorous
how much emotional eating have i been
doing and he delivers a seamless
american accent
even though his natural british accent
is quite thick
i don't speak ridiculous oh you're a
scream have a nice life goodbye
it honestly fooled us completely and we
would never have guessed that it was him
rashida jones daughter of musician
quincy jones and actress peggy lipton
has been acting since the late 1990s
some of her most recognizable roles
include comedic hits such as ann perkins
in parks and recreation
and her role as karen phillippelli in
the office are we taking this too far
you know what i don't think we're taking
this far enough she has had a long
prosperous career in cinema and
television
starring alongside andy sandberg and
celeste and jessie forever and appeared
in the historical drama the social
network as marilyn deppley in the grinch
she voices donahue the loving nurse and
hard-working super mom of cindy lou who
and brothers buster and bean
okay then well good luck and i guess
i'll see you in
about a month joan's voice is memorably
iconic
and she captures donahue's spirit with a
bubbly but raspy undertone
okay come take your seats everyone
dinner's ready in the grinch the titular
main protagonist
cindy luhu is voiced by 13 year old
cameron seeley
celie's voice takes on the character's
childlike spirit while also portraying
the more modern humorous perspective of
this movie's version
cindy lou don't worry mom
she is a junior actor and singer just
breaking into her cinematic career in
film
but she has already done so with a huge
bang she has already worked on the
greatest showman
alongside hollywood a-list actors like
zendaya hugh jackman and zac efron
she also starred in the jim gaffigan
show before landing the leading role in
the grinch
thank you santa good night
the happy singer pharrell williams the
seemingly ageless musical icon
stars as the narrator for this movie it
is christmas in whoville
the home of the whos pharrell is a
multi-grammy winner and nominee
he has over 10 wins and 40 nominations
to his name
he's known for his musical hits like
blurred lines and feels but this
talented composer has also worked on the
soundtracks for the despicable me
trilogy
the oscar-nominated film hidden figures
and the amazing spider-man 2
along with being a judge on the voice
williams is also a popular music writer
and producer he's helped write hits like
get lucky
drop it like it's hot and i'm a slave
for you his narration in this classic
movie adaptation is something we didn't
know we needed but
thoroughly enjoyed and three weeks
through december
this place hits its stride his smooth
voice glides us around the story
holds it all together and adds the touch
of coziness required for this holiday
special
and the luscious sounds swelled reaching
up to the skies
veteran funnyman keenan thompson plays a
new kooky addition to the grinch
franchise
he portrays the overly zealous christmas
obsessed mr bricklebomb
thompson's natural sense of humor made
this an obviously fitting casting choice
i myself use chocolate explosion
he is a long time cast member of
saturday night live and has also
appeared in various television series
he has starred in the unbreakable kimmy
schmidt as the character ronald and has
also lent his voice to television shows
such as nature cat and scooby-doo and
guess who
kanan's naturally smiley warm voice
brought the character of mr bricklebaum
to life come on give me a hug
it don't count if you don't hug back
buddy you may not immediately recognize
the name
angela lansbury but you may recognize
her voice she is best known for her
portrayal as mrs potts in disney's 1991
oscar-nominated film beauty and the
beast
after the cupboard with you now chip is
past your bedtime
she also starred as aunt adelaide in
nanny mcphee and she also appeared in
the 2018 version of mary poppins
have you forgotten what it's like to
hold a balloon
to be a child lansbury is a long time
actress in television film
and voice she has been in the game since
the early 1940s and has starred in films
such as the three musketeers and the
private affairs of bellamy during that
time
she has a collection of awards
nominations and accolades
including a television critics
association lifetime achievement award
in the grinch movie
she lent her voice to the character
mayor mcgurkle her charming voice made
the character more robust and jovial
it is time to light this beautiful tree
some viewers might not have guessed that
max the grinch's furry sidekick
was voiced by long-time voice actor
frank welker he's a legend in the world
of voice acting
you might recognize welker's voice if
you enjoy watching the mystery solving
gang in the scooby-doo franchise
frank is most known for his voice as
fred jones in the series
he has also done work for many other
childhood favorites
such as curious george animatics the
simpsons
bubble guppies and smurfs the lost
village he has also worked on numerous
other projects like the flintstones and
the transformers franchise
he has been working in both television
and film since the late 1960s
and won a daytime emmy lifetime
achievement award in 2016
as a testament to his work so having
this iconic voice actor play max
that was an easy choice what santa had
that i don't
scarlett estevez is most widely known
for her role as megan in daddy's home
and daddy's home too
she also appeared as trixie espinoza and
lucifer estevez voiced one of cindy lou
who's good friends
izzy in the animated grinch movie all
right we're in
great now let's do this izzy is also the
twin sibling to brother ozzy
this isn't scarlett's first go at
voiceover work either
she also lent her voice in the tv short
animated series if you give a mouse a
cookie and the anime series
modest heroes the role of ozzy is
portrayed by sam lavagnino
lavanino was born in 2006 and has since
appeared in television and film before
he landed his role on the grinch
come on it's not the school play dude he
appeared in the bravest warriors
and the disney series miles from
tomorrow he also lent his voice to the
peanuts movie
where he was part of the group voices
axel is part of cindy lou who's trio of
friends which includes twins izzy and
ozzy
ramon hamilton voiced the part of axel
in the grinch
what are you talking about personally
annie has appeared in hot in cleveland
blaze and the monster machine and modern
family
no never i'm on team crabs for a life
even though it's skipping theaters and
going straight to streaming we couldn't
be more excited about the spongebob
movie
sponge on the run our animated friends
might look a little bit different thanks
to stylized cgi
but many of our favorite voice actors
will be reprising their roles from the
show
we'll fill you in on who's who including
all new characters and where you might
have heard certain stars before
snoop dogg there's fast cars flashbacks
snoop dogg
obviously having snoop dogg join the
cast of sponge on the run is exciting
but which denizen of bikini bottom will
this legendary performer be lending his
voice to
well rather than using his iconic voice
on an animated character
it seems as though snoop dogg will be
making a cameo as himself
really snoop is such an intimidable star
that it makes sense he's portraying
himself
in this movie we'll see him laying real
low all the way at the bottom of the
scene
keanu reeves since counter reef is
constantly adding entries to his imdb
page it's not a total surprise that he's
one of the many voice actors and sponge
on the run
but that doesn't mean we're any less
excited to see him especially since we
have fond memories of his
semi-autobiographical role
as duke kaboom in toy story duke kaboom
canada's greatest stunt man oh yeah okay
so he's not the greatest stunt man but
he is a canadian motorcycle enthusiast
in spongebob on the run he'll be
challenging his sage wisdom by playing
a piece of stage call me sage good night
i'm made out of sage and i am a sage
so it works out pretty well spongebob
and patrick will undoubtedly need some
help tracking down gary
and it looks like keanu will be there to
help guide them on their quest
aquafina most of us probably know
aquafina thanks to her musical career
but this green tea singer also has an
impressive acting career
my parents did not name me aquafina yes
she was in the hit film crazy rich
asians as well as jumanji the next level
and ocean's eight just to name a few now
aquafina will be lending her voice to
sponge on the run
in an undisclosed role we'll just have
to wait and see if we can recognize her
voice
out of a presumably new character reggie
watts
another sponge on the run voice actor in
an undisclosed role is the
multi-talented self-described
disinformationist reggie watts and the
important thing to remember is that this
simulation is a good one
in addition to his comedy and musical
careers he also lent his voice to
pastry pete on tuka and bertie stay in
there
really breathe it in and asif on my
entire high school sinking into the sea
do you think you'll be able to recognize
his voice when you hear it in sponge on
the run
matt berry matt berry isn't a regular
cast member on spongebob squarepants but
this isn't the first time
dipping his toes into the franchise he
also provided the voice for bubbles the
dolphin and sponge out of water
would you mind keeping an eye on
christmas
but this time he'll be playing the
prestigious role of king poseidon a
character we don't know much about yet
we've seen king neptune on the show and
as you mythology fans may know
neptune is the roman god of the sea
while poseidon is a greek counterpart
it'll be interesting to see what exactly
these two characters have in common
jack gore spongebob did promise us
flashbacks in the super bowl commercial
for
sponge on the run so it's not totally
surprising that we're going to see
younger versions of some of our favorite
characters
young patrick starr will be played by
jack gore who's known for his work as
timmy cleary on abc's the kids are all
right sing a song let the world sing
along
tom mcgrath if you're a fan of the
madagascar movies then you might
recognize the voice of tom mcgrath
if you watch this you may explode with
excitement
he played the part of skipper the
mischievous penguin and co-directed the
films
and now he's going to be part of sponge
on the run as the appropriately named
light bulb bopped he may look like a
pile of parts but he acts as spongebob's
boat driver
which is probably for the best
considering spongebob's driving skills
he could have invested in a robot
earlier and saved poor mrs puff a ton of
trouble
stop i'm going to lose my teacher's
license tom kinney
if you're a fan of spongebob squarepants
then you've probably heard of the
legendary voice actor
tom kinney i'm known for doing spongebob
squarepants
his snell gary and the narrator who says
two hours later i was lay down he's been
working as our favorite sea sponge since
day one
in addition to some other high profile
gigs tom is the voice of the ice king
from adventure time
the narrator and mare from the powerpuff
girls and the dog and cat dog
according to tom his first big break was
as heifer on rocko's modern life
which is how he met stephen hillenburg
who would go on to create
spongebob squarepants apparently once
steven heard tom's voice he knew he'd
found his spongebob
as well as his pet snail the narrator it
just wouldn't be a spongebob movie
without tom kinney
jason maybaum we know it's hard to
imagine but squidward tentacles wasn't
born a grumpy adult
there was a time when he was a child and
actor jason maybaum will be providing
the voice for young squidward and sponge
on the run he might have seen him as
levi on the show's
raven's home no i'm not i'm a model
student aren't you right
antonio raoul corbo and let's round out
our look at younger versions of our
favorite spongebob characters
by talking about young spongebob
squarepants himself steven hillenburg
has joked that this character ages in
sponge years
so we're not sure how old he'll really
be in these flashbacks
but we do know that his voice will be
provided by antonio raul
corbeau who plays nikolaj on brooklyn
nine-nine
hi jake i love you nice to meet you mr
hanukkah bill foggerbach
now that we've had a look at some of the
younger cast members let's move on to
some classic voices from the original
series
where would spongebob be without the
help of his trusty best friend patrick
starr
friends don't let friends go on
dangerous quests
patrick is voiced by bill foggerbach who
will be reprising the role for spudge on
the run
in addition to his long-running voice
acting gig he's also known for playing
michael dauber dabinski on the classic
sitcom
coach i may be unusually flumuxed he's
been portraying patrick for over two
decades and says he's grown attached to
this particular sea star over the years
he's close with the rest of the cast so
reprising the rule of sponge on the run
was a no-brainer for bill
veronica alacino one of the many
mysterious entries on the movie's imdb
page is veronica alasino who's listed as
an unknown voice but what we do know
about veronica
is that she's married to tim hill who's
worked behind the scenes as a writer on
spongebob squarepants as well as
other films like rocco's modern life and
kenny the shark
as for veronica herself she's had a slew
of roles including marie mama luke
in the mama luke we'll have to wait and
see who she'll be and sponge on the run
roger bumpus is another long-term
denizen of bikini bottom and you might
recognize him
as the voice of spongebob's grumpy
neighbor squidward tentacles
spongebob what are you doing in here
according to roger he loves the
underwater world created by the late
stephen hillenburg
and finds a lot of humor in it unlike
his character squidward
when he first started voice acting in
spongebob squarepants squidward's voice
was much more monotone
roger claims that after everyone
discovered his ability to scream
as squidward they made sure to make his
character upset even more often
clancy brown not only does clancy brown
have a long career as a voice actor
but he's been in some memorable movies
as well he was byron hadley in the
shawshank redemption
35 000 that's what he left me and kieran
in highlander
but in the underwater world of bikini
bottom he's mr krabs well
usually some fans couldn't help but
notice that our favorite money grubbing
crab
sounded different in the games spongebob
squarepants battle for bikini bottom
and battle for bikini bottom rehydrated
that's because mr crabs was voiced by
joe white
instead of clancy brown a difference
that loyal spongebob fans definitely
noticed
but rest assured that clancy will be
back to reprise his famous role in
sponge on the run
mr lawrence give up world domination
give up world domination that's like
giving up show business
douglas lawrence osowsky is better known
as mr lawrence and he's been trying to
steal the crappy patty formula for over
two decades with no end in sight
like many other cast members he's also
spent time working on rocko's modern
life both as a writer
and as the voice of philbert not only is
he the voice of plankton but he's also
one of the writers behind spongebob
squarepants
which he says is a lot easier on the
vocal cords than portraying plankton
did i get it jill tally and where would
plankton be without his wife
karen plankton look how cute a baby he
is fun fact the character is named after
stephen hillenberg's wife
karen hillenberg and to make things even
more interesting the voice of karen
plankton
jill talley is married to tom kinney the
voice of spongebob
she's worked as karen plankton on the
show and now she's ready to take her
role to the big screen
carolyn lawrence we have seen plenty of
aquatic characters but now let's
celebrate our favorite undersea dwelling
lands mammal
sandy cheeks don't you dare take the
name of texas in vain
she's voiced by carolyn lawrence who's
grown attached to the role over the
years
she loves letting sandy sing even if
carolyn insists she isn't very good at
it
you might also recognize her as cindy
vortex from the jimmy neutron franchise
needless to say caroline is part of the
core cast who will be returning for
sponge on the run
faster than a barefoot jackrabbit on a
hot greasy griddle in the middle of
august
mary jo catlett poor mrs puff has been
trying to teach spongebob how to operate
a boat with no end in sight
oh spongebob why but behind the scenes
mary jo
catlett has been busier than most of us
realize in fact she was discovered by
stephen hillenburg
after he saw her performing on stage and
decided she would be perfect for the
part of mrs puff
she's been in many theatrical
productions including hello dolly and
beauty and the beast
mary jo enjoyed her transition to voice
acting so much
she stuck around for over two decades so
far lori allen
hey girl let's hang out since it seems
like the whole cast is getting together
for sponge on the run
mr krabs daughter pearl the whale will
be there too she's played by actress
lori allen who also plays diane simmons
on family guy
he promised to introduce me to dan
rather but instead he introduced me to
danny bonaduce
including films like toy story 3 and
inside out as well as shows like
futurama and cow and chicken
i'm getting a job today are you excited
to see sponge on the run even if it
won't have a theatrical release
let us know how you'll be streaming the
movie in the comments section below
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time